this is a production of Cornell
University
all right so the summit I'm giving today
is to celebrate the founding of the
Mason X corporation newsletter at
Cornell University by RA Emerson and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
tell you about our search for the first
Mays newsletter and some of the other
Mays newsletters that somehow were
missing from the library for a while and
how with the help of lots of people
we found them again and so it's it's an
interesting I hope you'll find an
interesting story I'm also wanting to
remind people that we have kosher for
Passover macaroons that I brought from
Pittsburgh okay those of you who are
celebrating Pesach which I am so happy
taste okay so I want to dedicate this
seminar to the legacy of RA Emerson and
to Mays co-operators worldwide and I am
proud to be amazed cooperator as you
will soon see okay so previously on PBG
I told you about the department of plant
breeding and it was its founding in 1907
by LH bailey Dean of the college he's in
the middle of the picture and uh Bailey
appointed Webber to head the new
department and it turns out I don't know
if any of you know this but Webber and
Ra Emerson were brothers and I may have
mentioned that to you before
and so when Webber was leaving Cornell
and going out to California to work out
there he need he wanted to recommend
that ra Emerson take his place at
Cornell but he couldn't do that because
he knows nepotism and all that so he
wrote to
Edward marry East at Harvard who Emerson
got his PhD with and he said would you
make the recommendation and so that's
what happened and it was recommended and
the rest is history
okay so now I'm going to tell you that
the history of a little bit of the story
of the maize newsletter so the baseless
letter as I said was founded by Emerson
and this picture of Emerson that we have
is an interesting picture in that it was
it was taken by a guy by the name of
Trevor teal we didn't know who Trevor
teal was when we found this picture in
our files and I was in the archives
yesterday and actually found a letter
from Emerson - Trevor teal who actually
had a photography studio here in so
that's who he is we thought he might
have been a student we weren't sure so
that I found that yesterday okay so the
maze newsletter for years and years it
was believed that the first maze
newsletter was sent out in 1932 and
that's because Rhodes believed that that
was the first major letter turns out it
wasn't the first maze newsletter as
identified by dr. Emerson was sent out
on 12 April 1929 so that was last week
and it was published through 1955 right
here at Cornell and then what is the
maze news let anybody know hey bye
letter is a collection of notes and
information unpublished mostly about
ongoing research shared throughout the
maze research community and Emerson
people trusted him so much that they
would send their data to him and he
would send it out in a newsletter to
people and say in order to go forward
and in maize genetics we really need to
cooperate and work together to make
things go faster and and and this is how
we're going to do it and people trusted
him so much that they said ok we will
send you our unpublished data not too
many people would do that today
so the publication of the base
newsletter is still extant and it became
fully and only electronic with volume 88
okay I have to do my announcements first
because in order for me to do this
presentation I needed the cooperation of
all these people all right so Edco who
was the former maize newsletter editor
from 75 to 2000 we've been in
communication like forever
Margaret Smith's I'll tell you a little
bit about her in a minute and how we
first met in this project Michael Cooke
from man library helped us with it
Judy singer less Judy singer Royce
Murphy I'll tell you about also how he
helped ed buckler mark Sorel's Bob
Robert cook and plant breeding and
genetics department and the Cornell
archives so there you go all right so
here I am I am a cooperator lbk that's
me I became a mace crow operator when
Edco asked if we could locate here at
Cornell the missing Mays newsletter
records of the cooperation and he wanted
to compile thank you
he wanted to complete the archival
records list that he had published in
1976
and so that's when I became amazed
cooperator it's very proud of that okay
so what are these historical notes what
was he talking about I had no idea so it
turns out that in 1940 justice Emerson
was about to retire he retired in 41
1941 there were he published Emerson
published something quick that's called
the historical notes on maize genetics
cooperation and he numbered those notes
1 through 14 in Roman numerals and Ed
said to me can you find the maize knit
those early maize newsletters at Cornell
I said sure Odom an library and I'll
find them did I find them in man library
no they were missing
so it's like wait a minute where are the
maize newsletters
so what do I do what everybody did you
go find dr. Murphy and you say dr.
Murphy I need help
where are the early news letters and so
there's me and dr. Murphy at the
celebration for the centennial of the
college and there he is on his tractor
um okay so he said go see Margaret Smith
she has the early news letters it's like
okay so as Margaret has told you before
I popped into her office and lo and
behold look what was there Margaret what
are they doing there what's going on how
come they're not in the library - about
- bound volumes days newsletters -
through 14 and 15 through 21 and there
they were but
I look at the back binder and it says
New York State College of Agriculture
copy - and it's got the
the library code on it and man library
hadn't been built yet and so when man
library was built the librarians decided
they were going to take the College of
Agriculture library
and subsume it into man library but they
made random decisions about what they
wanted to put in there and I guess they
didn't like the Mays newsletter so it
was a mimeograph you know a mimeograph
it was a mimeograph sheets mimeograph
sheets of paper that were put on a
stencil and you know you've sat there
and you went like this and they came out
and then you stapled them together by
hand all right
and then you mailed them you mailed them
off okay so Dana want him so somehow
they ended up they stayed in plant
breeding department department and when
Margaret came she was very interested in
corn genetics and so somehow she became
the Stewart
of these volumes so I bopped into her
office and I said can I borrow these
ever since they'd been in my office
so she said sure take them and so then I
contacted ed you know and I said guess
what Edie we only have volume to through
21 bound
um oh wait I'm getting ahead of myself
okay so the question was what are we
gonna do with these volumes
you know we're cleaning out what are we
gonna do let's send them to the archives
let's then we contacted the archives and
we said do you want these for the
history science collection
said absolutely but then I thought wait
a minute some of these you know people
other people want to see these things
what are we going to do with them
so I contacted Bob Cook who published
the previous two books you know the book
of the history of plant breeding and the
book on McClintock and I said Bob would
you like to have these scanned and make
a book out of them and he said yes there
are any money to scan them so we
contacted Michael cook to the rescue and
he said I can't stand them I can scan
them and I can digitize them so god
bless Michael cook and God bless Robert
cook because that's what we're doing to
preserve the volumes they also want to
go to the archives okay so if we go on
here where is Mays newsletter one which
was identified by Anderson with the
Roman numeral one he said this is news
newsletter 112 April 1929 and where's
the second folder of mimeograph data
that he sent out which was the first
newsletter was 30 pages long and it had
rainbow maps they hadn't even figured
out the chromosomes of of Mays at that
time that wasn't published by Barbara
McClintock until a couple of months
later so in April they were using you
know waynebow maps trying to figure out
where the genes belonged on the
chromosomes and by 1930 there was
another set of maps that went out and
they're not in this book okay and so
where are they okay
go to the rescue he says Oh guess what
in the EG henderson papers at the
University of Missouri
there is Mays newsletter 1:12 April 1929
identified by Emerson and there's also
communications by George Beadle 1929
which I found at the University of
Wisconsin and a 1930 communication that
Edie found siree
so the Mays newsletter one was actually
a compilation of data that Beatle George
beetle famous George beetle and dr.
Frasier from Cornell put together and
Emerson recognized that in this first
newsletter so the second folder of
mimeograph data ended up at the
Rockefeller Foundation it's like what is
this doing at the Rockefeller Foundation
so of course I had to go down to the
Rockefeller Foundation and find out I
love working in archives right so I went
down there and it turns out here's where
I found the answer I found the answer
because at the 1932 International
Congress of genetics
there was a meeting that took place
which is reported in Mays newsletter to
buy roads and the meeting says that
there was cooperating of co-operators
was formed at the International Congress
of genetics and they got together to
write a grant proposal that they were
going to send to the National Research
Council and they did send it to the
National Research Council and the people
from the Rockefeller Foundation had
actually come to Cornell to on another
purpose for another purpose and had
talked to Emerson and said listen you
know if you want we can help you with
this and Emerson said no no don't worry
about it I'm sending this to the
National Research Council I'm gonna get
a grant from them
well he didn't and so they said alright
send us what you have and resubmit to
the Rockefeller Foundation so in January
6 1934 he resubmitted and they gave him
five thousand dollars for pure research
and clearinghouse for corn genetics okay
but that was for the cooperation not
necessarily the newsletter okay the
newsletter was part of that but it was
we need we need money to grow corn at
Cornell and share the the corn crop with
people who are working on the linkage
maps because they you know they didn't
know the linkage map yet they're still
working on them and so the group
photographs that's here how do I do this
to me is that the pointer well you can
you know that that's a picture okay so
we found this picture of the
International genetics Congress and we
found this in the files at Cornell and
AG contacted me and he said you know
what I have a picture like that to which
I got at when I was working in North
Carolina and he said not only do I have
that one but I've got a bunch of other
pictures that
taken at this Congress and we couldn't
figure out what they were doing in North
Carolina these pictures but eventually
we did find out that there was somebody
from North Carolina who attended the
Congress and these pictures that would
take it people could purchase them and
he and they didn't frame them so he
found them in we were able to scan them
and that's gonna be part of our
forthcoming story okay all right so ad
at this Congress it was a meeting and
yesterday when I was in the archives I
found a note that on August 26th after
the general morning papers there would
be a group photograph taken so that was
taken on august 26 1932 these are my
notes from the archives yesterday about
the International Congress of genetics
all right so that's how the second set
of material ended up at the rock and
apparently they sent everything there
and never got it back because it's not
part of this file okay so here's a
picture of Morgan and Emerson at the
Congress and the reason I'm showing this
to you is because these two people made
big addresses and big presentations at
the Congress Thomas Hunt Morgan was the
president of the Congress and Emerson on
the right was the chairman of the local
committee this picture was taken in
world Strait hall and it was published
in the Journal of heredity ed buckler
has an original photo which we have
scanned and his forthcoming but he also
wanted to tell you something about this
photograph which I thought was pretty
funny that I found in the archives
yesterday and it's by Emerson I think
it's page 50 my notes page 15 here where
he says
let's see maybe I've got the wrong page
well basically the story goes that when
this picture was taken Emerson was was
sent a a bill by Trevor teal who took
the photograph and he said I think I
think I might have sent you this bill
mistakenly and Emerson writes back and
he says yes he says I ordered two copies
of this picture and I paid the lady in
cash at the desk so no problem and so
you miss a letter in the library that
says that it's a pretty funny okay so
here's the big here's the big story
about the maize genetics cooperation
that Emerson presented he called it the
present status of maize genetics it's
published in the Proceedings of the
International Congress of genetics and
it's based on data that people sent to
Emerson much of which is published in
the maize newsletter some of it not and
Emerson tells everybody about the maize
and cooperation and all the people who
worked on it and so I just want to read
to you this wonderful recognition that
Emerson gives when he starts his
presentation he says I cannot refrain
from noting here a very real advantage
experienced by students of maize
genetics I am aware of no other group of
investigators who have so freely shared
with each other not only their materials
but even their unpublished data the
present status of maize genetics
whatever of noteworthy significance it
presents is largely to be credited to
the somewhat unique unselfishly
cooperative spirit of the considerable
group of students of maize genetics in
this connection I want to gratefully
acknowledge the help of many persons who
have contributed directly or indirectly
to this summary statement of the status
of mr. nettles he delivered this on
Thursday August 25th 1932 at the
Congress on that the next day there was
a synapses
25th synapsis reunion and that was held
in the in in wheeled straight Hall and
here's a picture of the synapses group
so he was really busy he was the local
chairman of the committee he was doing
the 25th anniversary of synapses he was
presenting a paper he was going crazy
running this conference okay so there's
the maze newsletter all the people who
contributed to the maze newsletter sent
Emerson their data so that he could do a
present status of maize genetics at the
1932 International and everybody that
contributed he cites who they who they
were how they made their contribution
okay so here you go Emerson's historical
notes which is no more Roman numeral two
he says there was a cooperation of maize
geneticists planned at the Congress
that's all he says but we've got all the
information now to know exactly what
happened because there was a daily news
bulletin that was put out every single
day published and it said when there was
going to be a meeting where was going to
be and so that's what he was talking
about and roads in 1932 says the meeting
was held Friday August 26 and he reports
that in what Emerson considers to be
May's newsletter two rows considers it
to be wrote amazing as letter 1 ok so up
on here how do I make this uh-oh there's
okay so this is the living maze map that
they put together it was it was down in
the garden and then this was a picture
of the entire plantings that would done
the exhibits from the 1932 Congress and
it wasn't only maze it was you know
barley and and tobacco and wheat and all
these different things that had to be
looked after and taken care of for this
International Congress they started
working
this Congress in 1928 getting people
together and it's like boxes and boxes
and stuff down in the archives that
talks about the committees that were
formed and it just took a lot of work
okay so people said to me well worth
amazing newsletters already digitized
what are you doing why do you need to do
this and my answer is yes and no okay
and the maze gdb maize genetics database
which is an online database offered
co-operators reports and Edie Ted Coe
told me that yes they did offer them but
they had been retyped they weren't scans
they had been retype they were often
with many errors and if you went online
to look for a report it didn't tell you
who the person that submitted it was
affiliated with if you look at this
document you'll see that the way it's
arranged is it says contributed by let's
say Cornell University researchers and
then there's a list of reports okay
so all they did when they put the
reports online was put in the reports
but they didn't tell you who with the
affiliation of you of the University so
there was many affiliation it's missing
or introductory material was missing
from that original database that was put
online okay so how do we solve the
problem how have we solved the problem
of the original maze newsletters we
scanned the originals verbatim which was
done by Michael Cooke and Edco he sent
us mais newsletter one and Michael
scanned B's they have special scanner
and man library where they can open up
the book and put it on there without
having to take the book apart we're
scanning and then Michael Cooke said
that he would provide a Cornell ecommons
webpage with digital ml volumes 1
through 21 and that is done and then
forthcoming
is our published ebook that provides a
historical perspective on co-operators
and the digital contents of the Mays
newsletter dr. cook is working on that
right now as we speak
and then hard copies we have to have
hard copies for the library because us
old people don't trust technology and so
and dr. Cook said we really need to have
printouts we've got to have printouts
for the library and the archives so
there was no money in his budget to do
that and so I applied to plant breeding
and genetics and God bless the committee
that said yes you could have money for
this so we will have some funding for
plant breeding and genetics from plant
breeding and genetics for hard copies
for the libraries that we will
distribute ok so this is a little bit of
the legacy of dr. Emerson I say
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery and the Mays newsletter
included unpublished data unselfishly
contributed by geneticists from many
institutions and Emerson was honest
forthcoming he claimed no credit for the
assembling the first newsletter as I
mentioned and he told he told the the
co-operators that Fraser extracted the
published data
Emerson's graduate student at the time
George Beadle assembled all the
unpublished records and all the tables
and all the charts and this first and
unique cooperative effort was widely
copied
so thanks to Ross the first volume of
the Drosophila information service was
issued in March of 1934 and the original
is here Thank You Ross
courtesy of Bruce Wallace given to Ross
who was his postdoc and then became
professor at Cornell I went to interview
Ross and saw this on his shelf
this is Drosophila information service
one through eight starts in 1934 and it
it mentions the Emerson cooperation and
the Drosophila workers had planned to
establish a similar service to that of
nays workers now when I contacted the
former publisher of genetics who was jim
crow and told him that drosophila
information service wasn't first he
argued with me and I said sorry but I
have and if you look at the first one it
says we plan to establish a similar
services out of the base workers da
anyway this is it if you want to see it
okay so thank you Ross so this is the
first this is a photo of an image of the
first Drosophila information service
number number one March of 1934 and it
was edited by bridges and Emmerich's
demux was a former korn geneticist he
got his degree in coin genetics with
Emerson so he knew about the Mays
newsletter and of course bridges was
doing Drosophila genetics as you all
know and they got together and decided
to do that alright so again imitation is
the sincerest form of flattery similar
publication soon followed in 1941 we had
the mouse genetics news and then the
mouse newsletter in 49 and endres new
Ross Perot newsletter in 62 a rabid
abscess information service in 64
the worm breeders to get is that in 75
and it goes on and on and on so you
could find others and many others have
come and gone however the maze
newsletter and the Drosophila
information service continues to today
okay alright so who is this guy let's
talk a little bit about Emerson I went
upstairs to find the to find Amy and
found out that she was moved to the room
next door and I was looking at the
report that uh dr. serb had written
about Emerson a little story about him
but there's no picture on that in that
frame we need to put a picture in there
but um here's what we know in brief
about dr. Emerson he was born on May 5th
very soon we'll have his birthday 1873
he was born in New York pillar point his
family moved to a farm in Nebraska in
1880 he got a Bachelor of Science from
the College of Agriculture at the
University of Nebraska he graduated Phi
Beta Kappa and he was elected to Sigma
sigh in his senior year nobody ever
mentions that I found it in the yearbook
he became the assistant editor in
horticulture at the office of experiment
stations at the USDA just for a couple
of years and then he returned to
Nebraska and they just put their
yearbooks online so I found a picture of
Emerson here he is right there that's
dr. Emerson from 1899 in the yearbook
1899 University of Nebraska yearbook
okay he was he was a horticulturalist at
the Nebraska agriculture Experiment
Station and he was pretending he became
assistant professor than professor
horticulture and then head of culture so
he wasn't a plant breeder at Nebraska he
but he did
experiments in plant breeding but he was
a professor of horticulture then I guess
somebody said you better get a PhD so he
goes to Harvard and it's kind of
interesting the dates he was at Harvard
are confusing in the Harvard University
directory I found that he was there from
1910 to 1914 12 so I don't know which is
correct but anyway he was there for a
year he was at Harvard for a year and he
got his his you got a what they call an
SD which now we call a doctor Sciences
and he published a very very famous and
very important paper with East the
inheritance of quantitative characters
in maze which I'm sure you guys are
familiar with if you are a corn
geneticist okay
so then this is the first picture of
Emerson woops sorry go back first
picture of Emerson at Cornell he arrived
in 1914 July of 1914 he was here as the
head of the department until 1942 he was
in 21 he was starting botany in the
third edition in botany notice he was
elected to the National Academy Sciences
that's the amazed newsletter little
badge he founded the maze newsletter on
April 12th right here at Cornell he gave
the present status in 32 he he became
the second president of the genetic
Society of America was founded in 1932
and then the very famous first linkage
summary of maze was published right here
through the Cornell University
Experiment Station the first linkage
summary was published in 1935 and what
he done what he did was he was getting
all this data from all all the maze
geneticists that would not only in the
United States but all over the world and
he said do I do
I have permission to publish your work
and they most everybody said yes and so
finally this 1935 paper came out and
[Music]
Harriet Crichton gave me her copy of
that
and it's all marked up with all the
changes and I have it and I promised her
I would give it I would put it in the
Cornell archives so I've got that from
Harriet so this picture is interesting
because even though Emerson arrived in
July of 1914 the first picture I could
find of him at Cornell is the synapses
this is from our book Murphy and Cass
2007 from our book here's Emerson and it
was in it was a synapses Club picture
taken in the spring of 1915 and that
building anybody recognize the building
it's rice Hall that's where the
department used to be is in rice Hall
okay
so that tells us a little bit about
Emerson so the other thing that you
already know because I've told you about
this is that our a Emerson established
the school of plant genetics at court
now that was comparable so the Morgan
school of just offal of genetics at
Columbia University and what I would
like to say now is let us celebrate
honor and continued ever since legacy of
cooperation whoops go back here are the
co-operators everybody we this is
Barbara Everson this is Rhodes
this is Charlie Barnum and this is
beetle and beetles dog okay we don't
know who took the picture but it was
definitely taken down in the [ __ ] at the
shed in front of the shed you go down
there you can see the show okay and I
actually got this picture from William
bill Provine we'll Provine when the
synapses reunion occurred in 1982 Rhodes
gave Emerson a copy of this picture and
they made copies of it and when I went
to the archives at Indiana where Rhodes
papers are this picture is not there so
he may have brought the original and
gave it to us and then we made copies of
it and I don't even know if we're the
absolute original is but anyway that's
what we've got so the end of my
presentation here I just want to tell
you that this is the book that's
forthcoming Volume one we had a book in
two volumes because there's so much
there we call it the founding of the
maize genetics cooperation newsletter at
Cornell University a 90th anniversary
tribute it's edits
by me Edco michael cook
Margaret Smiths and Judy singer and what
we've done is this is going to be an
e-book you'll be able to download it
it'll have the scans of all of these
first Mays newsletters and with the
introductory material and as I said Bob
cook is working on this right now I said
please please send me a copy of the
cover so I could show it so and then
this is the last picture whoops the last
picture that I could find of dr. Emerson
which dr. monger gave me and he went
back to working on celery in his later
years dr. Emerson died in 1947 and that
that's the that's when the last volume
appears so we believe that Emerson was
the one who put these two books together
for the library
the first volume when he was about to
retire and the second volume a have to
you know they published some more and
they are going to the archives now okay
so that's where they will be but you can
get them you will be able to get them in
our when our book comes out okay so
that's all I want to tell you about our
hit our story but what I do want to do
is have a couple of people who have
participated in the maze newsletter and
the maze cooperation tell us a little
bit about their history with the
cooperation and so I've got Edie on on
tap first and Michael Scanlon said he
was teaching and it's gonna run back
from downtown and get here hopefully in
time to talk but Margaret said if he
doesn't get here in time that she will
tell you about her experiences working
with the maze cooperation okay so let me
put up the next slide this is
what I could find online at the mace
t-maze database about Edie
he was the first Mays conference
presenter in 1995 and he's presented a
lot at the mace conferences he gave her
a room he told me he never gave a report
to the MAL that's not true I'm now 76 mm
- you sent in a report it's all there
okay so they heat these up to his little
badges that they got the maze newsletter
so he's you can see he's the cooperator
if you want to find him online here's
the link so he was working on the maze
working group he was a plenary session
speaker he was on the conference
steering committee he was on the
Executive Committee he was a chair of
the executive committee and now he's a
member of National Academies there of
the National Academy of Sciences along
with RA Emerson so I'd like him to come
up and say a few words
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so the grill outgrowth of the base
newsletter
I think there's 600 people from around
the world
welcome to and that community has
expanded I came a biologist
archaeologist he was making them the
next generation effectively
any corporation that we talked about
here completed today we talk much more
about collaboration right operation or
something so that is it
but that level has been key to really
[Music]
feel exactly as he said I will also say
competition things as fast as you
possibly can but I think you can have
five versus maze we're competing for
figuring out pieces of genetics but you
don't fly and they have an interest to
terminate it's very useful how we call
them now they coopertition so you're
[Music]
back and read some of these when I look
at some of the research I'm interested
today they start exact same questions
obviously we've been phrasing into place
everything and I look back in my own
career well I never the other Emerson
dog-eater warm I've actually worked with
data some of that I pull directly out of
the mix and so I think these newsletter
is really
[Music]
both backwards Margaret I didn't know
you know I didn't do a thing I could
have done like that for you know so this
is one of the first places I look
because you can hide information here
that came together to ever be public and
yet it's and that can be a tremendous
resource so in order to have sunny works
the office opened it up to the first it
was actually our last exhibit case in
which would be displayed dr. Emerson and
changing exhibits at conferences work
together with current worth of the
department the cost of this case will be
approximately five hundred dollars it
went on in the next sections state court
they won't read too much less persistent
us learning co-op president problems and
future possibilities and it talks about
incentives from here the activities
problems of running the parking lot
eight hours that's by aging snit about
to soar remember this was in 1992 about
two hundred and twenty different teams
are at present in the stop serving every
three or four years since no special
storage facilities for a good assistant
the Department of plant breeding versus
labor two hundred copies of the
newsletter Market Street here in
discrimination grants which orders ever
mounted to one thousand nine hundred
dollars annually this is approximately
1500
so okay well I guess that Michaels not
here let me just quickly just show you
what is his cooperation is Michael
Scanlon is in not in our department but
he's in plant biology
he's a cooperator he got the ALJ Stadler
mid-career award in 2018 he was amazed
conference chair plenary speaker
conference steering committee on the
committee and
made many many contributions to the maze
newsletter you can look it up on at this
lips oh well there you go at that link
so anyhow thank you all for coming and
I'll notify you when Bob cook has the
book ready and you can download it and
if you have any questions you can ask
Margaret this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu